now to this story we've been following a
California surgeon who appeared on a
reality TV show is being charged with
drugging and sexually assaulting two
women his girlfriend is suspected of
helping with the attacks
police arrested dr. grant Robichaux and
sarisa Reilly last Wednesday
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is here with how
prosecutors say they are likely more
unidentified victims vlad good morning
this is really six story this is a
disturbing story good morning
prosecutors describe dr. Robichaux and
his girlfriend as an attractive couple
who lured victims into letting down
their guard the Orange County District
Attorney says videos found on robo shows
phone suggest the couple could have
assaulted several other women together
my name is grant I'm 33 years old my
profile name is in good hands it is 2014
reality TV appearance dr. grant
Robichaux charmed his way through three
dates I'm looking for that partner for
life on the now canceled Bravo show
online dating rituals of the American
male I want to know what's wrong with
you because you seem like too perfect
prosecutors say that same charm and
clean-cut appearance allowed the
orthopedic surgeon that take advantage
of unsuspecting victims we've all heard
of a wolf dressed up in sheep's clothing
while a wolf can wear scrubs or a wolf
can be a beautiful woman last week
Robichaux and his current girlfriend
cerissa riley were arrested and charged
for drugging and sexually assaulting two
women in 2016 according to authorities
they met their alleged victims at bars
and restaurants then brought them back
to roba shows apartment once they were
intoxicated in one instance they
allegedly supplied multiple drugs to the
victim then raped her while she was
prevented from resisting the alleged
victim went to Newport Beach police the
next day and a forensic exam confirmed
multiple controlled substances in her
system in January 2018 a police raid
found large quantities of illegal drugs
in roba shows apartment there are
thousands and thousands of videos and
images on roba shows phone yesterday the
Orange County District Attorney said
there could be several unidentified
victims based on some of the
videos the women in the videos appear to
be highly intoxicated beyond the ability
to consent or resist
prosecutors say Robicheaux and Riley
were active travelers and visited
several music festivals and large events
in the last three years including
Burning Man and the Dirty Bird campout
where they may have encountered more
potential victims we don't know how many
victims there might be out there we
don't want this to happen to any other
women prosecutors say there is no
evidence that any of the alleged
assaults took place in a medical setting
or that the drugs came from a hospital
roba shows medical license is under
review by the Medical Board of
California attorneys for he and his
girlfriend say their clients have been
aware of these accusations for a number
of months and they unequivocally deny
all allegations of non-consensual sex
those suspects are free on bail and of
those videos the Orange County District
Attorney says they have hundreds
hundreds that show different women I
will never understand how a woman could
help a man hurt another woman especially
someone they don't know one of the women
on the show he was on set he seems a
little too perfect there might be some
dark skeletons in that closet
there you go we go president Thank You
Vlad